how gun trafficking is another GI part
of the equation and part of the problem
down there as far as uh as far as the
amount of Munitions uh weapons and
now we were also getting uh tradecraft
material from conflict zones outside of
Mexico so
weaponized drones the first time we saw
uh some of those weaponized drones was
uh in Syria
and like like a few weeks later you know
grenades were being dropped on the roofs
of some uh public officials uh Bill
cartels are using drones yeah that's
been going on for a while there's a
place in Michoacan and has some pretty
interesting videos and the interesting
part of them is because the federal
police down there are actually working
hand in hand with a United cartels
unidos Group which is basically the
local cartels to try and fight off the
new generation cartel moving into
Michoacan so even the federal forces are
fighting with the cartels to try and
keep this larger cartel out and there's
videos of these uh civilian drones
basically dropping explosives uh they
found some explosive testing ranges out
there that are basically replicating
stuff that you would see the IRA use
during the con during the troubles out
there from homemade mortars
um you know IEDs have been used in
Mexico with that not that much but
they're they're making like a presence
again you know we don't have a lot of
ordinance around like Iraq but we do
have a big mining industry down there so
mining mining explosives of all kinds
are pretty easy to get
so you start seeing that and also I mean
there's some exotic Weaponry coming in
from the south now and from the ocean
that
some of it is probably a U.S military
equipment sold to various South American
governments that are now
not as stable as they were and they're
kind of making their way into black
market so a lot of those 50 cal and
vehicle mounted technical type machine
guns and some of the RPGs and
uh man pads or remote control guided
missiles that you that have been found
in cartel hands are probably come making
their way up from down south